this is what scientists imagine a moon
village would look like it would be
built from the moon's own resources its
metals minerals and water ice access to
water would be essential for those
living on the moon scientists think
there is frozen water trapped in craters
at the moon's South Pole but there are
many unanswered questions about it
recently clues to the moon's watery
poles have been found far away beyond
Mars in the asteroid belt NASA's Dawn
spacecraft has spent several years
flying through this crowded region of
space since March 2015 it's been
orbiting the largest asteroid their
Ceres and sending back images this is
Ceres northern polar region like the
moon its surface is pockmarked with
craters and like the moon some areas are
permanently in the shadows without
sunlight these dark corners are very
cold below 60 degrees Kelvin or minus
200 degrees Celsius they are some of the
coldest darkest places in the solar
system
intriguingly scientists have detected
water ice in a few of these cold areas
you can see it here the white spot
it took some clever image processing by
the research team to pick out the ice
from the surrounding dusty surface
although it's dark the ice reflects a
tiny amount of indirect sunlight
this is not the first time that signs of
water have been seen on Ceres in March
2015 the Dawn spacecraft spotted two
bright spots near the equator they're
thought to be salt left behind when ice
turned to water vapor at this latitude
ice doesn't stick around for long
but in the northern craters the ice gets
trapped and that's what makes this
finding significant now scientists want
to understand how the ice gets to the
northern craters in the first place
Ceres is thought to be one-quarter
frozen water most of it just below the
surface one possibility is that this ice
below the surface is ejected by huge
cryovolcanoes and then lands in the
polar craters this pyramid-shaped
mountain was spotted earlier this year
and rises four kilometers above the
surface of Ceres roughly half the height
of Mount Everest the ice could also come
from asteroids that smash into Ceres
throwing up icy debris from the
asteroids themselves or from the icy
layer below the surface of Ceres cold
dark traps for water have now been seen
on three planetary bodies on Ceres on
the moon and a few years ago on Mercury
this suggests that they are not one-off
phenomena but general processes that can
happen on any object without an
atmosphere telling scientists where to
look if they want to find water on other
airless bodies in our solar system
puzzlingly the bright spots that tell us
there's water on Ceres have not been
seen on the moon the Lunar
Reconnaissance Orbiter has detected
hydrogen a key ingredient of water but
we haven't yet actually seen the water
maybe it's mixed with frozen soil so it
doesn't reflect light in the same way as
the ice on Ceres that's one possibility
the hope is that by understanding water
ice on Ceres we could learn more about
ice much closer to home on the moon
enabling us one day to live there
[Music]